how many people here like turn based
games you know like the xcom style games
the old type of final fantasy tactics
games when it's this type of gameplay i
really gravitate towards it and i have
found another one for you guys and i
hope you know maybe we can talk about it
for a little bit let's talk about it
it's called demio for the pc it's on vr2
you can get it on oculus i don't know if
it's on the other vr stores i think it
is but don't quote me on that but we're
we're going to be reviewing the pc
version and shout out to them for
sending the code over here now you know
before we get on with the video you guys
know how it is definitely hit that like
button if you guys enjoyed this video
you can always subscribe to the channel
for weekly podcasts we do the iron lords
podcast every sunday at 1 p.m and we do
the attic show every wednesday at 5 p.m
now that any further ado this is my
review on demio for the pc
[Music]
what's going on you guys lord again here
coming at you with another review today
i'm going to be reviewing demeo you guys
know that i just reviewed games like
triangle strategy not too long ago so i
think some of you know how i feel about
these type of games now let me go ahead
and make this perfectly clear i was a
little bit stumped on how i would make
this review because i've never really
played a game like this this is a very
unique game it's called demio and it's
for the pc now i did play this on the vr
on the oculus and i really enjoyed it on
that platform it's actually the only
reason i really even gravitated even
remotely towards the vr space so you
could really take this game for any kind
of vr content from me in particular
isn't lord addict now let's talk about
demio in general demeo is kind of like a
board game like something like clue
um you know monopoly and i don't know if
there's an actual board game of demio
but i do know as of talking about the pc
version it's kind of a four player co-op
that you play with up to three players
and you roll a dice to see who goes it's
like a grid space like those old xcom
games
if that's the type of gameplay i feel
like you guys will really gravitate
towards it there are four characters
well five you got the assassin the mage
kind of like the tank the warrior i
think they call him a guardian the bard
and the wizard now let's talk about
these units these are the units you play
in the game now how the typical game
play of demio goes is every turn all
four players go they have two action
points and they get these cards now
let's talk about the cards a little bit
every card has
the amount of action points required to
use that card so let's go over the
different type of cards that i generally
saw in this game so it looks like there
were
you know support cards that required
zero so you could use them and still use
both of your action points such as
strength potions health potions then you
had class
specific cards that were designated to
the wizard or to the archer that you
could only get if he was that class now
every class had a card that was reusable
they could use it as many times as they
want but it had a condition you would
have to like wait a turn after using it
or the assassin he would have it to
where he could use the ability which
would be you know pretty much making
himself invisible on the map but he
couldn't regain that card while he's
invisible so he would have to be in
plain sight he would have to go out of
invincibility mode with invisibility
mode and then he would have to wait an
additional turn to reuse that card the
guardian had an armor ability where he
could put armor on himself and the
wizard could shoot lightning now let's
talk about the classes in general when
it comes to whether or not i felt like
all of them was fun to play now i felt
like the bargain had really unique
abilities i felt like the archer was
nice you could shoot two arrows i felt
like you know i really stay mainly stuck
to the assassin because he could go
invisible and he could be very
aggressive at the same time if he did
back attacks he would be able to do
additional damage depending on if he was
doing back attacks so
i felt like that was really unique and
that made the gameplay different than
using like an archer that you would
generally stay away from the enemies and
he had a lot of sight you know as long
as you could see down a
path he could pretty much hit anyone
down that road the only one i really had
an issue with is i felt like the wizard
isn't balanced enough i felt like
because he only has you know jolt attack
or spark attack i can't remember exactly
what it was called where he would shoot
lightning at them
some enemies are immune to stun and that
was the biggest reason you would use
that attack for and i felt like that
stone ability it was really uneffective
if they did have immunity to weak now
was it really decent if you could use
that ability known as stun in the game
and obviously stuns where they can't
move for a turn you could you could lock
people down and be able to handle other
enemies while you had these different
units stunned so you could handle those
other people now i did feel like the
wizard was too relying on other classes
i felt like you know you would have to
combine it with the archer's mark
ability to be able to fully utilize the
cards that the wizard had it's like i
felt like unless the wizard had his own
cards now because there will be in
situations in this game to where you'll
use so many cards you're pretty much
just using the card that can be reused
over and over again so like i said the
ability to go stealth with the assassin
the ability to shoot two times with the
archer and the ability to put armor on
yourself as the guardian those were the
repeatable cards and the wizard could
only shoot a lightning bolt that stuns
people so i felt like unless that wizard
had cards and class cards specifically
you couldn't really do too much with
that person i i don't know how you would
fix that but i do feel like there needs
to be some rebalancing with the wizard
now as far as the cards besides the
class cards there were cards that
everyone could use i did feel like some
of them were a little op that i felt
like that maybe should have been
ultimates that you could only use once
with each class i do feel like there
needs to be something else added on to
the card system in general than just
having that one reusable card you know
let the assassin do a certain ability
once a map or you know once an actual
set because that's how it goes in the
game is there's three maps to every
story and it gets pretty it gets pretty
difficult you know especially the second
and third map now i don't know if it be
scaling to how many players is actually
playing the game you know we could talk
even about that a little bit like in
demio if you play with one person you're
playing with one individual unit two
people two three people three four
people four like you would normally do
on something like this but i feel like
this is kind of similar in the vein to
something like you know divinity now
maybe it's not as high scale in a
different form of game as divinity but
it is kind of like you know that co-op
sensation playing it and i think dmio
really takes advantage the fact that you
do have the ability to play this game
with three other players but i feel like
where they fall a little short with
games like divinity is the fact that
when you play with only one or two
people and even just one person
sometimes you can't get three people
they should give you the ability to play
with multiple units for example if you
play with just one person let that one
person play with two units and the other
person plays with two units so you do
feel like you're still getting the full
experience of this game and not with
just you know one person played with one
unit and the other person played one
because i did feel like unless i was
playing with four people the game didn't
take advantage to what demiel has to
offer if that makes sense
now demeo does a really good job at
explaining a lot of things but i think
like you have to look up tutorials on
youtube to some mechanics that's in demo
that i feel like they should be more
open with it now they could have updated
stuff by the time of this review where
they update the tutorial but i did play
this tutorial and i didn't really see
them go into detail on some things like
for example if you use a strength potion
uh that step buff that you got from that
strength potion carries over to every
map so when you're in a store and you
see a strength potion you might not
necessarily think that that is a good
card and you shouldn't waste the money
to get it and we'll go about the store a
little bit in a little bit down the road
in the video but you know that's
actually a very good card that you
should definitely buy because it gives
you a permanent stat increase for the
remainder of that adventure you know the
three stages that i was mentioning
earlier and you know you know since we
brought up the store a little bit let's
talk about the story after every stage
of an adventure you will be able to go
to a store and use the gold that you
found throughout the map to buy cards
now like i said there's card systems in
this game you can buy class cards here
you can buy regular cards that go for
every type of class and you can buy
support cards such as health potions
strength potions i really enjoy this
because i love when games give you the
ability to buy stuff with in-game
currency because it gives you something
to look forward to it lets you play the
game kind of how you want to play now
you can debate whether or not they give
you enough play styles of every class
for example you really just want to play
the game the way these classes were
designed and there's not really a lot to
play that doesn't go against the way
they're designed for you know the
assassin they kind of want you to you
know kind of rogue around the map you
know scout around the map look for
chests stay invisible and do massive
amounts of damage through stealth
mechanics and through back stabs and i
think that maybe they can go a little
bit more to making more styles for every
type of class but that doesn't take away
from the fact because i felt like even
though that there wasn't a lot of
variety and gameplay from class to class
the gameplay from classic class was
amazing besides you know like i
mentioned the wizard earlier and even
the wizard was fun it's just though you
had to have cards to really use the
wizard too it's effective or you had to
really combine it with other classes
such as the the archer in the game and
the cards aren't really hard to come by
you know there is like a little icon at
the bottom right of every adventure to
where if you do enough attacks on
enemies you defeat enough enemies that
slowly fills up and you can actually
take your cards that you don't want and
you can throw it in that little bar and
you can give it more points and once
that hits 100 you get a free card now
what it looked like to me what i saw is
when you do that you get the class cards
and when you get the chest on the map
you'll get like cards that are affected
to every class now it might be the other
way around i can't exactly remember
which one was which but that's usually
how i saw that's usually how it came out
when i was playing the game now let's
talk about the overall feeling of this
game this is an amazing game you guys i
can't really stress this enough i was
beyond
excited that this game was coming to pc
because i love vr but vr sometimes
doesn't mix with me vr doesn't love me
and sometimes i want to play this game
but i'm like man do i really want to sit
in a room with that vr headset on and
sometimes i'll feel a little nauseous
playing it but when they came to pc i
was like now i can play this on my pc i
could still interact with people in my
room and i was really excited i do
recommend this game to you guys i feel
like demio is a fresh paint on a genre
that doesn't really get
innovation too much now clearly you can
argue that there's a lot of things in
demio that needs to be fixed like for
instance i said about the wizard i don't
think the wizard was you know capable
enough on his own without his cards i
think that you know maybe they need to
do a little bit more on the stats of the
game i felt like when you're the tank
you're the tank regardless i when i play
rpg such as this i like progression i
like growing with the character and i
felt like the enemies was growing but
throughout the stages i wasn't growing
unless i was using like you know a
strength potion or something and i felt
like they can you know do a little minor
tweaks to that because when you play as
a guardian which is supposed to be the
tank you can take mad damage he is tanky
but i felt like it wasn't necessarily
doing what i would like him to do
throughout the journey sure he could do
that at the beginning but by second to
third stage i kind of would want you to
be able to upgrade that initial ability
or something and you know it is what it
is i it's like i said i don't think it
takes away from the game that's just my
constructive criticism to making the
game better and you know with that with
the difficulty scale that this game has
because like i mentioned a little bit
earlier the game can be difficult you
know it go from stage to stage i feel
like they they have no problem swarming
you with enemies and they expect you to
use these cards to get yourself out of
these situations and i respect that i
like it you know i felt like maybe the
you know the the fact that you're using
a card system and a dice system because
um you know what happens is when you
attack people you roll a dice you can
theoretically get a skull and i felt
like having both of those
together might have been a little bit
more in the rng system that i'm willing
to really feel comfortable with but it's
like i said what's crazy is they did
stuff so well where i never felt like i
was annoyed or angry that i rode bad
dice i never felt like i got bad cards
and it frustrated me because they were
constantly rewarding with me with cards
and if you didn't like those cards you
can take those cards and dispose of them
to get more points to go towards
everyone's next cards and keep in mind
that that mechanic is for everyone it's
not just you so if everyone's got cars
that they don't like they can just get
rid of them and it builds that pull for
everyone to get new cars and i really
enjoyed that i think demeo has something
here i think that when they really
determine what they want to do with this
game and i feel like they have but
obviously games will change to a point
and once they feel the you know the
criticism for the community it might
push away a different way but i do feel
like the foundation for this game is
amazing and sure there might not be a
lot of content right now there's three
adventures with three stages on every
adventure and i would say a stage can
take you anywhere from an hour to an
hour and a half depending on how
skillful you are in this game i'm sure
there's some that can do it's quicker
but that's that's a pretty good amount
of content if you look at it that's
that's probably around 10 hours your
first playthrough of every stage and
i've played these stages multiple times
and i never felt like i was burnt out
even playing the same stage back to back
because when you're playing with friends
that's why i felt like you know when you
play with one other person let me
control two people because i can always
have that sensation because i don't
always have to find four people but you
know that's pretty much what i feel
about dmu i definitely feel like it's
worth the asking price for this game
which i'm pretty sure is 30 and the good
part about buying dbo on steam
is if you have friends that's playing
this on vr guess what you could play
with them it's got cross play i don't
know about cross progression i didn't
really see any settings to set anything
like that up but cross play is good i
feel like you know do cross progression
it would be better because you can take
your account from one of you know system
to another it might be on the actual
website i didn't really look too much
into that but crossplay works day one
and i have to give my hats off to an
indie company that could do cross play
more successful than some aaa companies
day one but you know that's pretty much
the dmio for pc review from lord addict
i would definitely say that demio on pc
and on vr in general is iron lord
approved for sure because i really
enjoyed it definitely got the iron step
i really need to make an animation to
put on these videos when i feel like i'm
feeling something man it's getting that
iron lord stamp you know i'm gonna work
on that that's gonna be addict's next
adventure to get that iron stamp emote
to put on these videos but you know
definitely go and buy that game i think
it's worth every penny i really enjoyed
you know the narrative focus that they
give you on here the music that's in
this game i really enjoyed the gameplay
for the most part you know it's like i
said there was some nitpicks i can give
and that's all i really did in this
video was nitpick stuff but everything i
enjoyed i played to its fullest i
probably got 30 40 hours between the pc
version and the vr and i loved every
minute of it and i think i'm going to
start streaming this game because it is
a nice game that you can stream and
interact with your chat now when it came
to the vr i didn't really want to stream
the vr version because vr doesn't really
look the greatest when you stream in my
opinion but i would definitely be
streaming this game i recommend it to
all of you guys and until next time this
is my review on demeo for the pc
particularly the steam version i don't
know if it's on like epic games or
anything like that but it's on the steam
version for 30 dollars and i highly
recommend it and until next time this is
lord adams and i'm outta here peace